a former federal prosecutor is promising
to
release the kraken to prove that the
2020 election
was stolen in sydney powell's words
during a wild press conference
president trump actually won the
election
in a landslide and the left and
the administrative state and the media
are trying to steal it from him
this is stunning
heartbreaking infuriating
and the most unpatriotic
acts i can even imagine
for people in this country to have
participated in in any way shape or form
and i want the american public to know
right now that we will not be
intimidated
american patriots are fed up with the
corruption from the local level
to the highest level of our government
and we are going to
take this country back we are not going
to be intimidated we are not going to
back down
we are going to clean this mess up now
president trump won by a landslide we
are going to prove it
and we are going to reclaim the united
states of america for the
people who vote for freedom those are
pretty big claims but
are they true the trump team seems to be
distancing
themselves from sydney powell the left
and the right
are uniting to attack powell and even in
some cases
demanding that president trump concede
and i feel as though
i am the last patient man in america
we will break down what's cracking i'm
michael knowles that's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
sydney powell will release the kraken i
will release all of the puns i am going
to use
puns of kraken in as many show titles as
i possibly can
and i also i'm going to take this
seriously i think a lot of people are
just
rushing right now to attack the trump
legal team or to attack trump
not just the left but also republicans
too as though we didn't have a legal
process
that is going to play out now of course
as part of that legal process
we are going to have to see some
evidence
and time is ticking for that evidence
which is why if you want to check the
time you've got to get yourself a
movement watch
we all know that 2020 is not playing by
any of the usual rules
the same goes for holiday shopping as
well between shipping delays between the
mess and stress of
in-store shopping experiences there are
not many great options but our friends
over at movement watches
have made gift giving easy movement
makes clean and modern watches blue
light glasses and accessories
they get great quality and style and you
do not need to break the bank to get it
so last year for christmas i got my
father a few gifts and i got
him a movement watch now um you know i
get a discount on movement watches since
their sponsor of the show
and they're so reasonably priced that
actually it wasn't like the most
expensive thing i got him
by far his favorite gift that i have
gotten him in years probably
feels like a four to five hundred dollar
watch but you won't pay that price
uh you can get them uh for a fraction of
that price actually they're designed
in-house in
los angeles check out movement's biggest
sale of the year with fast free shipping
and free returns
by going to mvmt.com
knowles my favorite comment by the way
from the show
on thursdays from vinnie durham who says
jeffrey epstein didn't kill himself but
he did vote
for joe biden that is almost certainly
true right
i'm not saying jeffrey epstein voted but
if he voted the guy definitely voted
for joe biden now that that is one
aspect of
uh voter fraud that you you've seen
historically in
the united states which is that uh
nefarious political actors
will fill in ballots for dead people and
you know you see this happen in every
election almost
to some degree so the question is does
it happen enough to throw an election
that's not though quite what sydney
powell is alleging here
there was a fairly long press conference
on friday with the trump legal team
rudy giuliani our friend jenna ellis and
cindy powell who was there they were
they were all alleging sort of different
things
and different aspects of the
irregularities that took place
uh sydney powell has gone the furthest
she's saying that there is
a conspiracy you know the the thing
about conspiracy theories is sometimes
there actually is a conspiracy
very often there are not but sometimes
there are
and she says she's going to release the
kraken for those who don't know the
kraken is a giant scandinavian octopus
it's a mythical beast that comes out and
rips sailors down to their watery
watery deaths and so she's saying yes
i'm going to release this giant monster
and show you
that there's this this giant tentacled
thing that is
all around our government so what are
the specific claims made in the press
conference the conference began
with rudy giuliani and everyone's
attacking rudy
because he's kind of an eccentric
character and it looked like his hair
dye was running down his face a little
bit
but i have to tell you i get such a kick
out of rudy giuliani
i absolutely cannot attack the guy one
thing that people kept
kept hitting him for is because he made
a reference to one of the greatest
movies of all time
my cousin vinnie did you all watch my
cousin vinnie
did you know the movie it's one of my
favorite war movies
because he comes from brooklyn and when
the nice lady
who said she saw and then he uh
he says to her how many fingers do i how
many fingers will i got up
and she says uh three
well she was too far away to see it was
only two
these people were further away than my
cousin vinnie was from the witness so
rudy giuliani is describing why
the poll watchers who were not
republican poll watchers were not
permitted
into the election centers in a number of
places around the country notably in
philadelphia even after there was a
court order
saying hey you crooks you got to let the
republican poll watchers in
in many places still wasn't happening
and even where republican poll watchers
were permitted in
often it was the case that the poll
watchers had to stand not just six feet
away
20 feet away 50 feet away from where the
votes are being counted
and so rudy's using this example from
mike has invented saying you can't see
that closely
that is a an evocative example it's not
they say why is rudy talking about micas
and vinnie well because he's giving a
news conference and he wants to get
people's attention that's a good way to
do it
another great moment during the press
conference again has
not terribly much to do with the
specific allegations themselves but i
loved it nonetheless
is where rudy taught the american public
a word of italian american slang which
is uh
stu nad you knew if you lived in
philadelphia
unless you do not that's an italian
expression for stupid
unless you're stupid you knew that a lot
of people were coming over from camden
to vote
they do every year happens all the time
in philly
it's about as frequent as getting beaten
up at a philadelphia eagle basketball
football game happens all the time all
the time
all the time stu nad this is it does
occur to me for people who are not of
italian
extraction or not from new york you
might not know that expression it it
actually really is
misstating it a little bit here it comes
from the italian word stonato which is
like out of tune
you know out of whack not not quite uh
on online not quite in
melody or in harmony so sure stupid
people are knocking rudy for this this
is
classic rudy this is why you hire rudy
giuliani he is not making an argument
for a judge right now some critics are
saying maybe they should focus all their
efforts
just on making arguments before a judge
but this is a press conference
this is designed to entertain you and to
grab your attention
and therefore thereby to give you the
facts donald trump does this very well
he makes a big big show and he gets
everybody's attention
and then people are paying attention to
what he is telling them that is what
rudy giuliani is doing here
i find it charming and i really enjoyed
it then
there was just one other moment that i
thought it was perfect i mean you can
see how rudy and trump have been friends
for decades now he's asked questions by
the press
and he takes some questions he doesn't
take other questions and
for one he could tell they were kind of
activists they were a little bit more
left-wing
so he asks them who are you with what
publication are you with
cnn
[Laughter]
perfect way to respond perfect way to
respond to cnn just laugh in their face
this is the difference you're seeing
between two types of republicans here
two types of conservatives the ones
who are are really nervous about what
the left thinks of them
and say that we need to rush to attack
giuliani
and jenna and sydney powell and trump
and we need to rush to tell him to
concede and we need to rush to say this
is all crazy and there shouldn't be
legal challenges the ones who are
i don't know what do you call them the
i've been calling them the court jester
conservatives the ones who are
willing to play according to the rules
set by
the liberals that's one type of
conservative here and the other kind are
the ones
who just laugh who laugh at cnn who say
i don't care what you think of me cnn
i don't care what you think of me
administrative state i don't care what
you think of me
left you have no credibility
left-wingers
you see this especially when the left
accuses conservatives of being racist or
sexist or whatever some ist
some ism word and there's some people
who say no no i'm not please you know
they really want to defend themselves
against
some columnist george and then the other
ones who say
who cares i don't care what you say you
have no you have absolutely no right to
say that to me you have no credibility
that's what rudy is doing and
you know he he might have eccentricities
he might have foibles his his hair gel
might run down his face
but that is the attitude that is the
only attitude that is going to be
successful i'm not
saying it will be successful but i'm
saying if we have a chance of being
successful
the only way to do it is to tune out
what the left is saying
to tune out the stunt left then he gets
to the specific
allegations okay and what rudy's talking
about here are voting
irregularities specifically the counting
of illegal
ballots now it's not necessarily the
case that the voters
themselves are ineligible to vote maybe
they are maybe they aren't but that the
ballots themselves because of the
mode in which they were transmitted the
mode in which they were counted
are themselves illegal and rudy thinks
there were lots and lots of these
illegally counted ballots
enough to throw them all out and
overturn some of these state decisions
there are sixty thousand ballots in
milwaukee county and forty thousand
ballots
in madison that
as far as we can tell and this is why
we've we're auditing
because we have very good information
the numbers are going to come out about
here
that don't have applications under the
law of the state of wisconsin
already decided if there's no
application
for an absentee ballot the absentee
ballot is thrown away
this all happened in two places in
wisconsin
didn't happen in northern wisconsin
didn't happen in
republican wisconsin it didn't happen in
neutral wisconsin whether an equal
number of republicans and democrats
it happened in a place where the vote
was 75
80 for the democrat of course
we know this we know that there are
these crooked machine cities
we know that all the irregularities were
happening in these crooked
one-party democratic-controlled cities
is it enough to throw the election
who knows that that's why there's a
legal process playing out
but don't look me in the eye and tell me
that everything was above board here we
know that it wasn't we know i mean just
to use that one example in pennsylvania
we know that crooked election officials
were violating court orders
for what purpose because everything was
above board i don't think so
we know that there were shenanigans that
went on
and rudy is making an aggressive case
that because of those shenanigans you
got to throw out those ballots
and if you throw out those ballots maybe
you can flip the states if you flip the
states
maybe you can flip the election very
important
to focus on ballot security that's what
that's what rudy's talking about it's
gonna be a little bit different than
what sydney powell is talking about but
we're really talking about is the
security of the ballot box
itself and you should also think about
the security of your identity this
holiday season
you can miss certain identity threats by
just monitoring your credit
and bank statements that's why you got
to get a life lock lifelock is the
leader in identity theft protection
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats such as
maybe number one issue your social
security number for sale on the dark web
if lifelock detects your information
being used in their network they will
send you an alert
if you become a victim of identity theft
lifelock can help you restore your
identity
easier than what you can do on your own
okay it is very easy for someone to
steal your information if you are not
being responsible for protecting your
data i know
this is the sort of thing you don't
think about i used to not think about it
very much either
it is unbelievable how vulnerable we are
when we go online when we use our
computers and our phones
to identity theft don't do it no one can
prevent all identity theft
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but lifelock can help you
feel warm and protected
this holiday season save up to 25
percent off your first year
at lifelock.com knowles that is
lifelock.com
knowles canadawes for 25 off
okay so rudy is making his
uh i think excellent point here about
wisconsin it's an aggressive point the
judges might not care they might throw
it out
there might be so many political
considerations they they can't do it
they don't want to over overturn the
election in these states there might be
not insufficient evidence we don't know
what rudy has but what he's describing
is pretty significant
then you get to the woman that
everyone's talking about sydney powell
city powell is not talking about dead
people voting sidney powell is not
talking about
the illegal counting of of ballots and
certain polling locations
sydney powell is alleging massive
widespread electronic voter fraud
she's specifically alleging that the
alphabet agencies you're talking about
agencies like the cia the fbi
that these agencies went in and
manipulated votes
she's alleging that the software that
we're we're describing here this
dominion software is
one piece that's come up smartmatic
another company that's come up
that this was uh done in uh this was
constructed in cooperation with crooked
governments that would steal elections
the alphabet agencies have been involved
in this and that basically there was a
massive not just national but
international conspiracy to steal
this election that is the claim actually
uh
not last friday friday before when when
i was filling in for rush
we spoke to rudy giuliani and he mayor
giuliani brought up that there were huge
shocking issues with dominion and
smarmatic so it wasn't just sydney
powell
making this argument though she was the
only one making this argument
at the press conference so
here is sidney powell's grand claim
one of its most characteristic features
is its ability to flip
votes it can set and run an algorithm
that probably ran all over the country
to take a certain percentage of votes
from president trump and flip them to
president biden
which we might never have uncovered had
the votes for president trump not been
so
overwhelming in so many of these states
that it broke
the algorithm that had been plugged into
the system
and that's what caused them to have to
shut down in the states they shut down
in so she's saying that and we remember
this on election night for some reason
the vote counting stopped
just for and and then in some places it
continued even though it was continuing
behind closed doors illegally not the
way it was supposed to be done
why did that happen sydney powell said
it's happening because people were
electronically trying to steal the
election
and so many people voted for trump they
had to go in and fix it somehow okay
we don't we don't have evidence for it
we just
have the circumstances that sidney
powell is bringing up and we have her
claims and and i
should point out cindy powell has had a
real career she was an
assistant u.s attorney federal
prosecutor
she was the lawyer for mike flynn so
this is not
you know some lady sitting with tinfoil
a tinfoil hat on
now i don't know maybe she's gone
completely insane that's an allegation
against her
maybe she is maybe she hasn't maybe
she's a very serious lawyer and she
actually has the goods we don't know
she has been going on news shows over
the past
weekend to give greater detail on some
of her claims
this isn't a summary judgment motion
where we actually have to produce any
evidence now your typical lawsuit
you just file the statement of what the
charges are without any affidavits or
anything
what are you saying they're gonna fight
why the media is going about this is
absolutely ridiculous and unreasonable
to
expect us to put evidence in right now
although we are we know election issues
are on an expedited schedule
but i could wait a month to file the
fraud case and everybody would have to
undo their certifications because it's
so bad
but are you saying you're going to
follow the same case in multiple
jurisdictions or in one jurisdiction
each one is a little bit different
depending on what happened in the state
the different manner and means and the
evidentiary aspects that support each
one
you know we've got different affidavits
from different witnesses in each of the
states
so they're going to be some differences
between them but they're going to be
claims that are
identical some of the legal claims are
going to be identical
for example in a number of states the
there were modifications to the machine
after the statutory cutoff date
that should invalidate every vote cast
on the machine
so she's sticking with her story and
she's giving
more examples though we haven't seen a
ton of hard evidence just yet
since these interviews the trump legal
team has distanced itself from sidney
powell they sent out a message last
night said
sydney powell is practicing law on her
own she's not a member of the trump
legal team
she is also not a lawyer for the
president in his personal capacity
that was a memo that came out from rudy
giuliani and jenna ellis who
are on the trump legal team now in the
past president trump has described
sydney powell as a member of the trump
legal team i don't know that sydney
powell has ever described herself
as a member of the trump legal team i
think she's described herself as a
supporter of the president but i haven't
seen her do it news shows have described
her as a member of the trump legal team
but again i don't know that she has
herself
now powell for her part has responded to
this statement
powell for some reason was kicked off of
twitter when all of this came out
so she couldn't defend herself on
twitter it's a little strange and powell
responds and says i understand today's
press release
i will continue to represent we the
people who had their votes for trump and
other republicans stolen by massive
fraud through dominion and smartmatic
and we'll be filing suit soon the chips
will fall where they may and we will
defend the foundations of this great
republic
hashtag kraken on steroids so so sydney
powell
totally doubling down and unless you
think by the way
that the trump legal team is is totally
shocked by what
sydney powell is saying go back to the
the rush limbaugh show
not not the you know three days ago not
this past friday but the friday before
that when i was filling in
rudy giuliani bringing up similar issues
maybe not with the same ferocity
maybe not with the same uh
grandiosity but he is bringing up the
same issues with dominion
and smartmatic what do we make of all of
this i think that
just about every single person in
politics
on the left and the right is getting
this issue
wrong so i will tell you the correct way
to view this issue
but first we we got to thank our friends
over at acre gold
here is something new you know that the
price of gold has been skyrocketing
lately right
and you know that it's difficult to buy
gold because gold bars are expensive and
we don't all have zillions of dollars
lying around we say oh yes honey when
you go pick up
the milk today could you get me a few
bars of gold please thank you no gold
gold is expensive to invest in
acre has figured this out they have a
tremendous new way to invest in gold
acre lets you subscribe to gold bars for
as little as 30 bucks a month
but gold bars cost more than 30 bucks a
month so how do you do it you pay each
month and once your gold stash reaches
the price of their gold bars
they will discreetly ship you acre gold
to your house acre lets you invest in
physical gold
without coming out of pocket all at once
acre keeps you updated on your gold
stash every month
and ships once you reach the price
threshold with acre taking physical
delivery of your gold means that it's
safe and sound and in your hands
acre also just recently introduced their
new hundred dollar per month
subscription
for their five gram gold bar i
personally enjoy investing in
physical precious metals i've i've done
it myself
sweet lilies has done it i i enjoy that
it's as conservative as i think in
general like to know that they've got
some of their investments in physical
stuff that they can touch visit get acre
gold dot com slash knollscanner wlas and
start investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to this url because
acre's giving away a gold bar to qualify
for that giveaway tweet or post
why you should be the recipient and
mention at get underscore acre
that is getakergold.com knowles thank
you acre gold for supporting the show
what do we make of all of this is sydney
powell single-handedly saving the
republic
is sydney powell completely insane is
president trump going to win the
election
is president trump destroying the
republic by not conceding
oh my goodness gracious am i am i the
last
patient person in the world
am i the last calm
non-hysterical person on planet earth
sometimes it feels that way we have
liberals on the one hand disingenuously
demanding that president trump concede
before the legal process plays out
before the process within our
constitutional framework
plays out then on the other hand we have
fretful conservatives
nervously demanding that trump can see
it as well
and even more of them attacking powell
first chance they get
even you know prominent cable news hosts
who usually are considered pretty
conservative or usually pretty hardcore
slamming powell why
i think my take is completely different
than all of these my take
is uh chill calm down
there's a process here they will have
their day in court sydney powell will
have her day in court
she will file her claims and argue them
before the judge or she won't if she
doesn't
then obviously she doesn't have the
goods if she does she will argue the
claims
the evidence will be presented then
maybe the evidence will be convincing
maybe it won't
even if the evidence is convincing maybe
the judge won't care anyway
but maybe the evidence isn't convincing
it'll be thrown out and then we will
know who the president is when the
courts
make their ruling has
has everybody forgotten that patience is
a virtue
it's okay you don't need to we don't
need to rush
to slam some conservative lawyer we
don't need to rush to concede an
election
we also don't need to rush and say there
we have 100 proof that the election was
stolen
and biden's completely ill we don't need
to rush toward any of that
it's not going to do any good is it
there is a process that is going to
decide
who the president is whether we like it
or not
and that is that's not even just some
process that was cooked up in the last
five or 10 years by some nefarious
progressives that's a process that we've
had for centuries in this country and
that's what's going to happen
and and there's no reason necessarily to
overthrow that
there's no reason to rush that process
as well bush v
gore lasted something like 38 days
how many days are we into this now we're
20 days in
okay seems to me like we still have time
and there are a lot more states up for
dispute there's a lot more evidence of
irregularities today in the 2020
election than there ever were in 2000
with the hanging chads
in florida the election is not over
but there is a distinct or i suppose
maybe a more
than distinct possibility that when this
process plays out in court
the courts will name joe biden the
president
and joe biden i'm sorry to say has not
been instilling
confidence in all of us if he does
ascend to the presidency take a listen
to some some soaring rhetoric recently
from mr biden they talked about that in
some detail
thirdly we discussed the need to help
states with title 32
funding for the national guard that's a
fancy way of saying
governors governors need to be able to
get
funding when they dispel when they just
they need to uh and bring bring their
national guard into play
and national guards are going to have to
play this it cost a lot of money
ah yes i forgot about the what was that
huh would you say
come again what the biden team has been
doing with what liberals have been doing
is they're blaming this
on joe biden's childhood stutter
you see so if you in any way question
joe biden's mental faculties
if you in any way question his ability
to communicate ideas
you are you're mean you're cruel you're
ableist
you are making fun of this trait that he
had
no control over that he's had since he
was a child the problem with that
argument of course is that joe biden's
childhood stutter
mysteriously disappeared for 70 years
right he i guess he had it when he was a
child he's 78 years old now
he had it when he was a child then it
went away
and then he had a 50 year political
career what
47 years to be precise 47-year political
career no stutter
no the childhood starter was fixed and
then the childhood stutter comes back
at age 76 77 78
that's no longer a childhood stutter
that's something different that's
evidence of cognitive decline that
i don't think anybody if you caught any
of the biden staffers in a moment of
honesty
i don't think any of them would deny so
then
joe biden clarifies quote unquote what
he's thinking
we talked a lot about with the
governor's about what the immediate
needs are i'm going to
we're going to impose the we're going to
enforce the excuse me
employ the defense reconstruct the act
to be able to go out there and dictate
companies build and do following things
we need much more testing we need much
more masking i mean that's more we need
gloves
i asked them east to go and ask the
national governor association through
the governor
cuomo and the ones on the line to let us
know what their shortages are what they
anticipate
this is so embarrassing ever the left
has been saying now for years that trump
is so embarrassing donald trump is
pericles compared to joe biden donald
trump is
abraham lincoln in his soaring oratory
compared to joe biden and in his
moral clarity and in his political
vision the clarity of that vision
it's very difficult to believe the
claims of voter fraud that are be
that specifically they're being made by
sydney powell not
not because i don't think it's possible
that they have i think it is possible
it's just
because of how grand it would be
it because of how significant
that kind of an issue would be if really
you know the bureaucracy and the
administrative state are colluding with
these
these different election officials in
already we know corrupt states and
cities
to to steal an election on a massive
organized scale
which is which is different than just
you know an irregularity here and a
little crookedness and a little cheating
here and there so it is hard to believe
that i'm not saying it's impossible but
it's hard to believe that
then on the other hand it's much harder
to believe the deep staters the
bureaucracy the administrative state
that spied on president trump in 2016
that tried to stage a legal coup d'etat
in the ensuing three and a half years
through countless investigations through
a completely illegitimate impeachment
and so forth so it's you can't believe
them you certainly can't believe them
and and
you certainly 100 can't believe the
media who have
spent not just years but decades lying
to you
who do we believe my take is we wait for
the evidence
just we stay calm stay cool when you get
really worked up when you get really
angry when you get really red in the
face
you make mistakes you do things that
you'll regret later
stay cool don't let them don't let the
left
troll you into that kind of madness
stay cool stay calm have faith it'll
work out you know there's that line my
my friend and priest father rutler
george rutler says difference between a
scottish optimist and a scottish
pessimist
scottish pessimist says things can't get
any worse
scottish optimist says oh yes they can i
think that same thing can be said of
conservatives
you know it might this might not work
out we know it's a certain point the
culture is going to keep getting worse
and worse and worse and
that's something we can be sure of and
so we'll we will just have to wait and
see
grit and bear it and have courage which
is the prerequisite for
all of the other virtues and we can
fight back you know our wonderful press
secretary kelly mcinanny is fighting
back that
press secretary who makes all of our
conservative hearts go pitter-patter
we'll get to her
in a second you know thanksgiving is
almost here that means that black friday
is almost here too
since last year's black friday deal we
have been consistently adding more
features
and products to our membership program
and we're really excited about it
to name a few things we've added more
exclusive readers past content
our insider and above members can now
stream our content
on apple tv and roku and we are
currently adding the entire prageru
catalog behind our paywall which i think
is really great because i have a show on
prageru
called the book club and you'll be able
to get that show behind the paywall
daily wire
your account now comes with custom
badges that you can earn by
participating in current events
if you're an all access member you get
to join all access live or exclusive
daily live streams
with me and the other hosts and more
importantly
the members of the daily wire elite all
accessed here
from whom i regularly steal ideas and i
look forward to stealing your ideas as
well
so you definitely got to go to all
access you also get not one but two
leftist years tumblers
early access to our daily wire merch and
daily wire discussions
with our writers and special guests
we're also continuing to add new
features and products
such as you know obviously the prageru
library we're also adding
candace owens over here who will be
launching a new show with us next year
so
needless to say we're very excited about
this year's black friday deal you won't
want to miss it
we'll be right back with a lot more
while we wait well we try to figure out
what happened in 2020 we don't need to
just roll over you know we can
push back where we can rudy giuliani did
that
and kaylee mcinadie doing that as well a
bunch of those hyenas in the press
pool were screaming at her in the white
house briefing room and she made clear
she feels no obligation
to call on radical left reporters
thank you everyone for the very good and
substantive questions
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't call on activists nor should she
nor should she i'm all for calling on
real reporters who are having a good
faith conversation but not for activists
this is actually something that i i've
realized
uh in online discussions
in public debates you know whenever
people challenge you to a debate or
these sorts of things
i think it is good to have good faith
debate
i think that is a good i love doing it
it's one of my favorite things to do
and i think it is not only pointless but
damaging and counterproductive
to engage in bad faith debates there are
a number of leftist blue checks who all
they
want to do is make bad faith arguments
and then if you kind of poke some holes
in those arguments and you try to take
the discussion
further to a deeper and more interesting
place they won't do it
maybe because they're not capable of it
but certainly because they're not
interested in that
you have no responsibility to engage in
that kind of a debate i actually think
it's
it's just a temptation and it's
something wrong to do to engage in that
kind of debate and that's what kelly
mcinerney is saying she's saying i'm not
no
i don't i don't talk to act i talk to
reporters if you if you want to be a
reporter
i'll talk to you if you're just going to
be an activist that's not what this is
for that's not what the white house
briefing room
is for speaking of activists in the
media
there's there is one who just went a bit
viral
for expressing a view that i think is
actually pretty common on the left
and it is it should make us all just a
wee bit worried if joe biden becomes
president
the pulitzer prize-winning art critic
jerry saltz i believe he said was he a
new york times magazine or so he's
somewhere he's a very prominent art
critic
jerry saltz is now suggesting that
republicanism conservatism should not be
tolerated
he writes republicanism is no longer a
political problem
republicanism is a social problem it
must be treated in the same way
coronavirus
is treated it has to be isolated and
snuffed out by repressing it in about 70
percent
of the population isolated and snuffed
out
this first of all jerry saltz probably
knows more about art than i do may i
assume he does
he might not have the correct views on
are but at least in terms of
just knowing of that he might he might
that's his area of expertise
but he doesn't know a damn thing about
politics just listen to this
nonsense sentence republicanism is no
longer a political problem
it is a social problem political
problems are social problems and social
problems are political problems
politics means what we do together
politics means
how we all engage and live together it
comes from
the greek city state the paulus that's
what it that's all it means
the left has tried to narrow the realm
of politics it's ironic what the left
has done
is both make everything political your
sneakers are political the coffee you
drink is political everything now is
political the shows you watch the sports
you watch are all political
except for politics then politics is no
longer political areas that are
open for public debate by citizens
are now taken out of that political
sphere
so everything it's their views are are
totally contradictory on this
but the reason is in a traditional
american
polity we might just if you wear a
certain set of sneakers and i wear a
certain set of sneakers
we just choose not to engage in that we
we we think okay that's sort of beyond
the realm of important political
discussion yeah it's public yet i guess
it relates to how we are
but we're going to we're going to focus
on the issues that really matter
we're going to prioritize our issues and
what the left has done is totally flip
that so all the really important
questions
how our government is set up how
elections are conducted who gets to come
into the country
uh whether you can kill babies whether
you can execute mass murderers or
serial killers or rapists or or
teenager murderers you know which we're
actually going to get to in a second
that is taken out of the realm and
that's given to experts and scientists
and lab coats who are deemed to rule us
better than we rule ourselves
this guy went viral and people are
attacking him for it i i don't think
he's calling for
the mass murder of conservatives as some
people do i don't think he's even
particularly radical i think this is the
mainstream
mainstream left-wing in liberal view i
think he's just saying
out loud which is that conservative
views are illegitimate
they should not be permitted in the
public sphere we need to re-educate
all the conservatives so that they are
they're not conservative anymore
and they need to get with the program
because progress is now
it's no longer a matter of politics it
is a scientific matter we're going to
give it to the experts the constitution
is inadequate to govern the country
we've got to be governed under this
organic bureaucracy that's going to
maybe it's going to be a little
capricious but it's going to have energy
and pull us toward utopia
and toward progress i think that's what
they believe i think that's what
progressives have believed since at
least woodrow wilson
and this guy's just saying it it's about
time that we recognize it
because the left is becoming more brazen
in the way that they're trying to bring
that about if
joe biden becomes president especially
if
those two republican senators in georgia
lose their runoff races
we're in a bad position the the
democrats have already told us they're
going to get rid of the filibuster
they're going to add two new states
they've promised us dc and puerto rico
which would fundamentally shift the
balance of power in the country would
destroy
the republican party at the presidential
level it would destroy the republican
party as a national governing party
they would obviously institute
their radical agenda issues like the
green new deal
mass redistribution of wealth a new
racial caste system which they've been
pushing for
all those sorts of things that is now a
mainstream view now there is some
pushback
there is a little bit of push i mean the
place you see the the
scientific view of politics most clearly
is with this coronavirus
epidemic where the the experts who now i
guess rule us more than the elected
officials
they just change their mind one day they
say you can't wear a mask it's the
scientific you if you wear a mask you're
an idiot you're harming people
then the day after that they say you
have to wear a mask if you don't wear a
mask you're harming people
and we just have to pretend like they
didn't say the other thing the day
before we just have to pretend like
they're not contradicting themselves
we're not allowed to ask a question if
you even ask a question
you are killing people because you're
depriving the scientific government of
energy
and that is uh irresponsible it's
reckless
it's anti-american there is some
pushback against that
against that creeping bureaucracy that
governs according to quote unquote
scientific norms that's outside the
bounds of constitutional government
just up in buffalo new york a guy had
his business raided
by these thugs from the government these
thugs came in
and they wanted to make them wear masks
and they wanted to enforce all of these
capricious rules that are written by
egghead bureaucrats and
change every single day and this
business owner wasn't going to take it
anymore
and this business owner stood up to
those cops and told them to get out of
his store
people actually work for their money and
they don't want to lose their livelihood
i've lost friends who've killed
themselves i've seen clients
die because they've lost their
livelihood i'm sorry to hear that i know
you are and i'm just a pal i'm asking
for you to guys have some compassion
for the people that have lost everything
we do have compassion for
people okay well you need to go have
compassion out in the parking lot this
is private property
this is private property this is private
property
it's private property listen man this is
private property they're not wanted here
so do your jobs well her job is well no
no your job is to remove people that are
not wanted here you have a school
don't worry about my health my health
isn't your concern you're meant to be
wearing a mouse because
okay
you have to leave you guys have
i don't know why that one sheriff's
deputy sounds like he's vaguely
british or canadian or something but
it's so fitting because you get this
american just
just great american man and he's like
get out of my business
you people are violating the law gtfo
basically right that's that's the
subtext of everything he's saying and
then this
this ridiculous bureaucrat this
this awful uh underminer of our
of our legal order because he goes
you're meant to be wearing a mask
you're you you come on you should be
well where's the law show it's so do you
should wear a mask
it's not a big deal well if it's not a
big deal why are you invading my
business
larry isn't it doesn't this risk more
lives
by you coming in here you could spread
it who knows it could be a super
spreader event
no it's just a flex of power were you
meant to be wearing a mask
no i'm not i'm not meant to be wearing a
mask i'm a human being
and i'm meant to breathe fresh air and
i'm meant to be a social
creature and i meant to see other people
and see smiles and communicate with
people because that is the
what perhaps the defining feature of my
humanity so i'm not
meant to be wearing a mask
these guys don't back down and finally
because they can't produce a warrant the
cops they can't they got nothing
finally they leave
it's not the law it's the code that some
bureaucrat wrote okay so you have no
legal remedies to that
you guys just start chanting this he's
just
[Applause]
[Applause]
the americans won't let us come in and
take away all of their rights and
invade their businesses yeah damn right
damn
right the left
the left is furious that they can't come
up with new codes every single day
capricious new regulations and enforce
them willy-nilly
but then the left is furious when just
laws are actually enforced
give you an example uh just over the
past few days
orlando hall was executed by the state
or
orlando hall and people are very upset i
think he was a black man so they're
making a racial issue out of this
as well obviously has nothing to do with
his crime or the
way he was convicted and the way that he
was executed but
they're trying to make a racial issue
out of it then they're trying to say the
death penalty is illegitimate per se
here's one writer from the atlantic
there will never be a day when the death
penalty is anything other than utterly
cruel and barbaric
but this execution is made particularly
horrific by the fact that orlando hall
is the first person to be executed by a
lame duck administration in over 100
years
no he was executed by the criminal
justice system
and a lame duck administration is
another term for the administration it's
another term for
the duly elected president and the man
who's tasked with the responsibility
to execute the laws and when the law
says so to execute criminals
ayanna presley who is the ringo star of
the squad says we must abolish the death
penalty joe biden same thing expresses
his opposition
to the death penalty this is one area
where
conservatives sometimes go a little
squishy and get it wrong
probably because they're following their
right lights you know but they just
they're they just get it a little off in
the beginning who was this poor man
who was executed by the state orlando
hall
uh was convicted of uh kidnapping a 16
year old texas girl
then repeatedly raping her then
bludgeoning her on the head with a
shovel
but not killing her he uh buried her
alive after he bludgeoned her with the
shovel
and then because she didn't die he
doused her with gasoline
and lit her on fire that guy that's the
guy
that's the great cause that the left
is taking up so it's wrong for the state
to kill a man
why why according to what standard
christianity uh the bible explicitly
defends
st paul explicitly defends capital
punishment
great doctors of the church explicitly
defend capital punishment say thomas
aquinas explicitly defends
capital punishment well the no the
church though catholics in particular
talk about this
many popes not only defended the death
penalty
they carried them out blessed pope pius
ix
carried out many death penalties in
the papal states justice
is an important thing mercy is wonderful
too especially at a personal level
but justice must be carried out the idea
that you can take
give a man i don't know 30 years or 50
years in prison
and that that's totally fine not not
morally questionable at all but that by
killing a man
for the crime letting a man stand up and
hang or stand up with a cigarette in
front of a firing squad and take his
just punishment
that that is somehow unjust immoral
it's morally incoherent to say that
totally incoherent
the victims here have some claim to
justice
and the state has a responsibility to
exact
justice you know the left does pick very
unpopular issues here very very it's
very bizarre obviously their their
crazed opposition to the death penalty
would be one example
but another example would be this green
new deal so aoc
i was holding just to show you the
popularity of the green new deal 93
trillion dollar program that would
utterly upend american society and
basically overturn the constitution
aoc holds an event for the green new
deal she's there she's in the background
these two activists show up and they're
so earnest and they're so ready
oh my gosh you can hear the enthusiasm
in everybody's voices
we're about to sing a song called we are
standing for our futures if you know the
song
sing along if you don't know it listen
and then sing in when you figure it out
all right we are standing for our
futures we
are healing what is wrong we are
standing for
our futures and together we are strong
you see like two people in the
background clapping even aoc can't
really muster the energy to do it we are
standing for
our
[Music]
not the most creative lyric either i
might contribute
one more time one more time one more
time everybody
please any of you can you sing along now
aoc is trying to
end this please you're making money
legislation looks so sad
we are standing for our future is that
going to be our future is the green new
deal going to be our future
is the administrative state going to be
our future is seeding more and more
control
over to absolutely idiotic
scientific eggheads going to be our
future
or are we going to take our future back
there's a process that's going to play
out we're going to have to have patience
and we're going to have to keep fighting
i'm michael knowles this michael knowles
show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva and production assistant
ryan love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there